a heavy rain moving towards northern
California is expected to complicate the
search for victims in the state's worst
ever wildfire 870 people in the affected
area north of Sacramento are still
considered missing a campfire is now
blamed for at least 81 deaths meg Oliver
is just outside paradise California
where she spent the day with a woman
searching for a lost family friend Meg
good morning John good morning paradise
is built on a mountainside raising
concerns for mudslides rains are
expected any minute now strengthening
throughout the day crews are racing
around against the clock to find human
remains before they're washed away we
talked with one woman who refused to
give up hope that her loved one made it
out of paradise alive
Diana Sauer spent the day Tuesday
handing out flyers I was told there's a
board down here by the cafeteria that I
can post this she visited seven
different Northern California shelters
hoping to find 70 year-old Russell
Anderson he was my father's best friend
when I was a child it's been a difficult
challenge Sauer says Anderson lived a
hermits life he had no phone and she is
just a couple photos that are decades
old how emotional is this for you oh
goodness I cry a lot I pray a lot it
kind of feels like I'm searching for a
needle in a haystack
hers is a search multiplied hundreds of
times over with so many still missing
after the campfire devastated an area
bigger than 115 thousand football fields
we surveyed the damage with CalFire
operations chief Josh Bischoff
about how many people were trapped
[Music]
any area that hasn't this much dense
vegetation the fires will be very fast
and so four people get out of its way
sour knew the odds were against finding
the man she calls uncle Russ I'm just
kind of hoping that it's a miracle and I
find them before I head home today
three hours later shower stopped her car
to share some very good news what did
you find exactly I went to evacuation
centers and I found his name and his
truck on a registration card just to
know that he got out safely it means
everything she was so happy now a
shelter worker didn't know where
Anderson had gone but Diana had to leave
to get back to her kids three hours away
she is hoping he will call her now
Anderson does remain on the
unaccounted-for list because officials
tell us you have to have direct human
contact before you are removed gale yeah
but at least she got some encouraging
news
thank you very much Meg
[Music]